The Joint comprehensive plan of action
was signed in July 2015 and endorsed by
the United Nations security Council
it was meant to limit Iran's nuclear
program in exchange for lifting
sanctions and allowing Tehran back into
financial markets after Decades of
isolation signatories were Iran and the
five permanent members of the U.N
security Council and Germany but just
two years after it was implemented the
United States pulled out of the deal
saying it wasn't a good one and imposed
thousands of new sanctions on Iran prior
to 2015 when the deal was signed there
was this dichotomy inside the country
that there's kind of debate whether we
should trust the United States there is
now a consensus both among the public
and political allies that the United
States is not a partner or is not a
country to be trusted when it comes to
International deals
in response in May 2019 Iran announced
it was resuming nuclear activities and
not abiding by the restrictions set out
in the agreement
four years later it has expanded into
new areas of research such as enrichment
uranium to 60 percent and using more
efficient centrifuges
these moves have raised questions about
tehran's commitment to returning to a
deal because the capabilities and
knowledge gained can't be reversed for
example in 2016 analysts estimated that
it would take around about 12 months to
build a nuclear weapon under a restored
deal now that time frame is about a few
weeks
although Tehran maintains it is not
seeking a nuclear weapon the
international atomic energy agency says
it is virtually blind when it comes to
monitoring Iran's nuclear program and
that's causing alarm in Washington it is
a genuine danger to Regional security
and to Global Security and indeed to the
United States of America and we are
going to continue to take action uh to
yes deter Iran from getting a nuclear
weapon and then to seek a diplomatic
solution that puts this on a long-term
pathway of stability that stability may
be a long way off as attacks such as
this one at natan's nuclear plant have
taken place over the past few years Iran
blames Israel which denies any
involvement as long as this Shadow War
continues there seems to be little hope
the 2015 agreement can be salvaged
highlighting the need for a new deal
Tehran